- That looks pretty good, right there,
that looks good to me.
- Yeah, that's okay, it looks alright.
- It looks like the swamp
from "Star Wars," dude.
- Oh, it does!
(upbeat electronic music)
- I eat to live, but I don't live to eat.
- My diet's pretty much
Chipotle and In 'N' Out.
- Soylent in theory is really cool,
but in practice, it just seems terrifying.
- I'm pretty sure I'm gonna hate this.
If I come out of this
and my life is changed,
yeah I'll say, "I owe you my words"
and say, "I was wrong."
But, I don't think I'm gonna be wrong.
- I think it'll be great though.
I have high hopes.
- I'm really scared to give up food,
but I'm also very excited
to try something new
and stick to it.
- It is day one.
We're about to make our
Soylent for the first time.
And, to do that we have
a packet of Soylent,
ice and water
and a bunch of oil.
- And that's it, that's a meal.
That's cooked.
Here's to a great week
of being sludge buds.
This is morning one after
a full day of Soylent.
I felt simultaneously full
and hungry all day yesterday.
My friend's eating a hamburger.
I have never been more
jealous of anyone in my life
than I am with him right now.
Well, Wednesday lunch is here
but I'm not gonna be having any of that.
Here's what I'm having.
Oh, hey look, there's
some vomit on the stairs.
And here's my dinner.
Always having a great time.
Shut up, Patrick.
It's day four.
I've been needing luck since Tuesday.
I'm sad and kinda delirious.
So, earlier this week,
we calculated how many
calories we needed to eat
and I've been following
that pretty closely.
I haven't been feeling too hungry.
- The other night I was falling asleep
and I just started thinking about bread.
- It has saved me a lot of time.
- Some bread is like,
very porous and airy.
- I pooped like one time
this entire process,
which is bullshit because I love pooping.
- Other bread's like, cakey.
- I definitely feel like
Soylent is a lot healither
than the usual garbage I put in my body.
- What was the question?
- So, as far as the physical benefit
to eating like, a
nutritionally-balanced paste
it seems to be working out okay.
- Tacos again.
The whole company's getting tacos.
What a fabulous day
for them.
- Do you think it's
cheating if we eat beer,
drink beer and Soylent diet?
- Personally, you have my blessing.
(screams in pleasure)
- That is good.
Good morning, everybody.
You know what today is?
Today is the last day of Soylent.
- I fucked up.
I ate a cookie.
I feel pretty guilty about it,
but I also feel incredible.
- I've had my dinner.
I've had my last Soylent meal.
So, here we are.
- This past week, there were a lot
of highs and lows.
It was a real roller coaster of emotion.
- I lost three and a half pounds.
I think that's important.
State the facts out-right.
- I lost somewhere around five pounds.
I don't think I need to lose weight,
that wasn't my goal here.
- I actually gained two
pounds while on Soylent.
- I can see the benefits
because I did save a bunch of time on it.
- I think if you're a really busy person
who doesn't have time to cook
or to eat healthily,
then Soylent is a very good alternative.
- After this interview's done,
I'm gonna go into a straight chain spiral
and just gorge myself.
- Food's great.
Don't, don't ever take food for granted.
It's the best.
- Do Soylent if you think
it might be right for you,
but ween yourself into it.
- It's just so sad what's
happening over there.
- Oh yeah.
You don't know the half of it.